lex what do you really want to talk
about
that's my always my question to you it
always gets me that's a good thing
maybe you are the therapist but like you
and i could talk about
anything people love up until now at
least
people have loved listening to the two
of us in conversation
and my feeling is is that we're not
talking about neural nets
we're not talking about geometric unity
and we're not talking about where
distributed computing might go and i
don't think that we're
really focused on
some of the most exciting things we
could do to transform education we're
still
caught in this world of other people
that we don't belong i don't belong in
the world as it's been created i'm
trying to build a new world and
i'm astounded that the people with the
independent means to help build that
world are so demotivated
that they don't want to build new
structures
and the people who do want to build new
structures seem to be wild-eyed
while i do what do you mean by wild eyes
they're not they're not i guarantee you
that i will get some message in my dms
it says hey eric
you know i'm a third year chemistry
student
at uh you know south dakota state and
uh i've got a great idea i just need
funding i want to build
they don't have the means so the people
who have the means
or the sophistication you know it's like
you're looking for somebody
who's proven themselves a few times to
say you know i've got four billion
dollars behind me
uh that's soft circled i want to figure
out what a new university would be
and what it would take to protect
academic freedom and who we would hire
and what
what are the different characteristics
because i can clearly see that
everything following the current model
is falling apart
nobody in my understanding is saying
that nobody is saying
um let's take that which is functioning
independently
and make it less vulnerable let's boost
those
those signals and a critical component
as money you think
it's not only that but it's also a kind
of these people are mobbed up hands off
let's imagine for the moment that
sunder pichai jack dorsey and mark
zuckerberg
um founded a
university come social media entity
and they said this is the purpose of
this is to make sure that academic
freedom will not perish from this earth
because it's necessary to keep us from
all going crazy
we are going to lock ourselves out we've
come up with this
governance system and the idea is is
that these people
will be assigned the difficult task of
making sure that society doesn't go
crazy in any particular direction that
we have a fact-based reality-based
feasibility-based understanding we can
try to figure out where our real
opportunities are
so it feels like everybody with a pizza
with the ability to do something like
that
and with the with the brains and
experience and the resources
would rather sit in the current system
and hope to figure out where they can
flee to if the whole thing comes apart
well yeah i mean maybe to push back in a
little bit i i agree with you but
you know it feels like there some people
are trying that so for example
google purchased deep mind uh deepmind
is a company that kind of represents
a lot of radical ideas they're they've
become acceptable actually
agi artificial general intelligence used
to be
really radical of a thing to talk about
and deep mind open ai are two places
which has made it more acceptable i know
you can now start to criticize well
they're really
now that has become acceptable they're
not taking the further step of being
more and more radical but you know
that was an attempt by google to say uh
that let's let's try some wild stuff
sort of like boston dynamics for like
boston dynamics
boston dynamics is a really good example
of uh
trying radical ideas for
perhaps no purpose whatsoever except to
try to try
out their ideas the idea is that
innovation
is like dessert you can have dessert
after you solve
the problem of the main course and the
main course is a bunch of insoluble
problems
so that is we can get into innovation
sure once we be
once we perfect ourselves and you're
saying that we need to make innovation
the the main meal well i'm saying that
there really is
structural oppression i mean if you
train
uh a
deep learning system on exclusively
white faces it's gonna get confused yeah
so let's not
disagree that there are real issues
around this
in fact that's an issue of innovation
and data
your data should be responsive on the
other hand
there are things we can't do anything
about that are actually
you know fundamental and um
those things may have to do with the
fact that you know some of us
taste cilantro as soap and some of us
don't
like there are differences between
people and some of them are in the
hardware some of them are in the
firmware some of them are in the
software
that is the human mind and
this completely simplistic idea that
every failure
of uh of an organization
to promote each person who has
particular intersectional
characteristics
we cannot hold progress hostage to that
and you've talked about perhaps we'll
save this for another time because it's
such a fascinating conversation you
talked about
this with uh glenn beck is the whole
stagnation of growth and all that kind
of stuff your idea is that
in as much as the current situation
is a kind of uh ponzi scheme the current
situation in the united states
is a kind of ponzi scheme built on the
promise
of constant unending innovation
we need uh we need to
fund the true innovators and
uh encourage them and empower them
and sort of culturally say that this is
what this country is about
is well let's put it this way the
brilliant minds we're gonna kill each
other
if we don't grow growth is like an
immune system
and you always have pathogens present
but if you don't have growth present you
can't fight the pathogens in your
society and right now the pathogens are
spreading everywhere
so if we don't get growth into our
system fairly quickly
we are in really seriously bad shape
so it's very important if i had a
horrible person who was capable of
building something that would give us
all
a certain amount of what i've called
financial beta to some new technology
where we all
benefit let's say quantum computing
comes in and everybody
the dry cleaner has a quantum computing
angle right
yes okay that's necessary to keep this
system that we built
going we can try to redesign the system
but our system expects growth and we've
started
starved it for growth and the madness
that we're seeing is the failure of our
immune system to be able to handle the
pathogens that have always been present
so people you know can say well this was
always there yes it was what's
changed was your immune system we have
got
to make sure that one we understand
why diversity is potentially really
important
we have mined certain communities to
death you and i are ashkenazi jews
everyone knows that ashkenazi jews are
good at technical stuff
we know that the chinese are good at
technical stuff the indians have many
people who are good at technical stuff
as
the japanese i also believe
that we have communities where if you
think about the pareto idea of
diminishing returns if you've never
mined a community
many of the people you're going to get
at the beginning are going to be amazing
because that community it's like did you
drill for more oil in texas texas is
pretty thoroughly picked over
do you find some place that's you know
completely insane
maybe there's oil there who knows
in particular i would like to displace
our reliance
on our military competitors in asia in
our scientific laboratories
with women with african americans with
latinos people who are in different
categories than we have traditionally
sourced and i would like to get them the
money
that the market would normally give
these fields
were we not using visas in place of
payment
right now
i partic i have crazy idea which is that
i play
you you and i both play music and i find
the analytic work that i do when i'm
trying to figure out chord progressions
and symmetries and tritones all these
sorts of things to be very similar to
the work that i do when i do physics or
math
i believe that one of the things that is
true
is is that the analytic contributions of
african americans
to music are probably fungible to
science
i don't know that that's true it's true
i haven't done
controlled research but i believe it is
very important to let the people's
republic of china
know that they are not staffing our
laboratories anymore
and that we need to look to our own
people and in particular
we are going to get a huge benefit from
making sure that women
black americans latinos are in a
position
to take over some of these things
because many of these communities have
been
underutilized now i don't know if that's
an insane idea
i want to hear somebody tell me why it's
but i believe that part of what we need
to do is we need to recognize that there
is there are
security issues there are geopolitical
issues with the funding of science
and that what we've done is we've
starved our world for innovation and if
we don't get back to the business of
innovation we should be doing diversity
and inclusion
out of greed rather than guilt now
part of the problem with this is that a
lot of the energy
in behind diversity and inclusion is
based on guilt
and accusation yeah and what i want
is i want to kick ass and my hope is is
that diminishing returns
favors mining the communities that have
not been traditionally mined
in order to extract
output from those communities unless
there's a flaw in that plan if there's a
flaw somebody needs to tell me if there
isn't a flaw
we need to get greedy about innovation
rather than guilty about innovation
that's really
brilliantly put my biggest problem with
what i see is
it exactly speaks to that in in the
discussion is diversity
it's used when it's grounded in guilt
it's then used as a hammer
to shame people that don't care about
diversity enough f that [ __ ]
okay so my point is
i'm excited about the idea of jimi
hendrix doing quantum field theory
i'm excited about the idea of of uh art
tatum trying to figure out
what the neural nets figured out about
protein folding
i have some idea of the level of
intellect of people who have not
found their way into stem subjects in
incredibly technically demanding areas
and if there's a flaw in that theory i
want somebody to present the flaw
but right now my belief is is that
these things are merit-based and if you
really believe in structural oppression
you do not want an affirmative action
program you want to make sure that
people have
huge amounts of resources to get
themselves into position
i want to push out i just tried this on
this clubhouse application
i want to push out klein bottles as a
secret sign
inside of rap videos in hip-hop right i
want people to have an idea that there's
an amazing world
and i want to get the people who
hopefully i'm trying to lure
into science and engineering i want to
get them paid
i don't want them as the cheap
substitutes for the fleeing
white males who have learned that they
can't make any money in science and
engineering
yeah so the problem is is that we need
we need to take over the shiplex
and it doesn't need to be you and me
because quite honestly i have no desire
to administer i don't want to be the
chief executive officer of anything
what i do want is i want the baby
boomers
who've made this mess and can't see it
to be gone
they they had almost all of our
universities
and i want fresh blood fresh resources
i want academic freedom and i want greed
for our country and for the future to
determine diversity inclusion as opposed
to shame and guilt which is destroying
our fabric
that's as good of a diversity statement
as i've ever heard
you